the
realm do you know what the realm
is it's the Thousand Blades of agon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a
lie well my friends the day is finally
here we now have our first look at House
of the Dragon second season HBO Max has
finally and officially released their
first teaser for House of the dragons
new season the first thing I have to say
is it looks absolutely incredible as I
said in my last video I believe this new
season of House of the Dragon will be
far better than the first season now
it's starting to feel like Game of
Thrones all over again and I for one am
very excited the war of Ravens and
envoys and marriage alliances is over
and the war of Fire and Blood has
officially begun the dance of the
Dragons will highlight House Targaryen
in a way in which we have never seen
them before now I will go over every
shot in this video and describe what I
believe believe is happening do not
watch this video unless you're ready to
find out what's happening in these
scenes with that being said Shall We
Begin the new video begins right where
we left off at the end of House of the
dragon's first season it begins with a
shot of rira overlooking shipbreaker Bay
where her son lucaris valeron and his
Dragon lost their lives this is where
their bodies fell after amon's Dragon
vagar devoured them in one bite as you
can see the devastation is written all
over rira's face as her worst fear is
confirmed her son lucaris is gone and
this will start a war that will nearly
wipe out all of House Targaryen and
their dragons after this we're shown
King aegon Targaryen as he's about to
ascend the Iron Throne as we all know
rira's father viseris named her his Heir
before he died rera should be the one
who is ascending that iron throne but as
we all know the greens held aegon's
coronation before rera even knew of her
father's demise in this season we will
see rera fight for what she believes is
hers by right in the following shot we
have we have Damon dressed in full body
armor leaving what I believe is Dragon
Stone this might be happening at the
beginning of the season when he leaves
for harrenhal we're going to see Damon
lead the assault on heral for rera and
this will be the opening of hostilities
in the dance of the Dragons we'll also
see Renea and Damon's men setting up
camp in an unknown location there's also
a shot of House High Tower's Army as
well while they're on the Move dressed
in full body armor it's no secret aegon
and rera will be fighting over the Iron
Throne so we will see them maneuver
their soldiers during the whole season
it won't be long before we see them in
the field fighting during an incredibly
bloody battle at rook's rest it's
followed up by a shot of Allison and who
I believe is Sir L strong they're
basically discussing what we will see
this season they will fight many will
die and the Victor will sit on the Iron
Throne now in this new season sir
Christen Cole will have a slightly new
look with his shorter hair in this scene
we see what appears to be sir Christen
Cole beheading Lord darkland after they
sacked DUS and Dale for those of you who
don't remember Lord darkland set on
Rene's black Council therefore sir
Christen Cole beheads him for treason he
will only be one of many men who will
die for siding with rira here we have
our first official image of aegon
sitting on the Iron Throne as you can
see he's wearing the iron and Ruby crown
of aegon the Conqueror I'm very excited
to see what aegon does to hold on to the
Iron Throne while rira and Damon do
everything they can to make sure he
doesn't sit there for very long in this
season we're also going to be introduced
to Adam of Hall who will be one of the
bastards from driftmark who gets
legitimized during the dance of the
Dragons we should also see him become a
knight and heir to house valyon now
since he's of Dragon Seed descent he
will be able to ride a dragon which we
will see him do right above his head we
see the dragon sea smoke formerly
written by Lenor valeron who faked his
death and fled Westeros in the first
season Adam of Hall will ride his Dragon
into battle during the dance of the
dragons and I believe we see him riding
SE smoke right here men from the green
army is then seen entering the field at
rook's rest this is where this season's
major battle will be located if you've
been watching all of my other videos
then you know what happens during the
battle you'll see more images of what
happens here soon here we have a shot of
some of rira's black Council we have
Damon rira rainy and Eric Cargill who
fled from King's Landing with the crown
last season they're most likely
strategizing how they will attack
aegon's Army we get an incredible shot
of Damon slicing down with his sword in
a godswood you can see the red leaves
from a were wood right behind him I
believe this might be at heren Hall
after Damon takes over the castle now
what we see next might be my favorite
frames from this teaser trailer here we
have am on D ey walking in the throne
room by himself he has that same look in
his eyes we've all seen before whenever
Littlefinger or even Varys gazed upon
the Iron Throne this should be when Amon
is Regent while aegon recovers from his
injuries suffered during the battle at
rook's rest I just love how these images
are shot in darkness while the lightning
strikes overhead it makes for an
incredibly ominous moment in the series
now we'll go up north where we see
there's snow all over the ground it
looks like this might be our scene with
the Night's Watch This will be after
Jace goes north to Winterfell to make an
alliance for his mother after Jace
becomes friends with Lord C and Stark
they will go to the wall together it
will be interesting to see what exactly
happens while they're with the Knights
watch at the wall as I've said in other
videos there is some evidence we will be
seeing the army of the Dead this season
but we shall see here we have another
scene with aliceon high tower and I'm
not exactly sure where this is it
doesn't look like King's Landing but I
might be wrong now I want to have a look
at one of my other favorite shots from
the video which is right here I love
this image of rira who has her Dragon
Cyrax watching her back it looks to be
on the beach of Dragonstone while rira
meets with Adam of Hall who's now riding
sea smoke right outside of the city of
King's Landing we see the Dome Dragon
pit at Top rainy's Hill you will become
very familiar with with this location
during the season of House of the Dragon
we were here in season 7 of Game of
Thrones when Daenerys met Cersei only it
looked much different then in this shot
Helena looks very upset and she has
every reason to be if you know what
happens to her this season unfortunately
she will be the one who pays the largest
price for Damon and rira avenging her
son Luc car's Damon will have assassins
hired known as blood and cheese who will
slip into the red keep at night now
because lucaris was killed Damon wants
revenge he wants a son for a son this
will be when blood and cheese enter
Helena's Chambers and force her to
choose which one of her sons will die it
will without a doubt be one of the most
heartbreaking and tragic moments in the
show her son little Jar's will die and
his funeral ceremony will be held in the
streets of Kings Landing we've seen set
leaks from that several months ago here
we have even more amazing shots from the
battle at rook's rest as I said in my
last video we will see many main
characters during the battle aegon Amon
sir Christen Cole and even rain will be
here before it's all said and done we
will see this Green Field soaked with
Fire and Blood we also have our first
official shot of Damon's daughter Balo
riding her Dragon Moon Dancer we're
going to see over a dozen dragons this
season unlike anything we've ever seen
before we also see the streets of Kings
Landing are in absolute chaos everyone
is running in fear but I'm not exactly
sure what's happening in the scene I
haven't seen King's Landing like this
since the NYS engulfed the city in
dragon fire and while we're speaking of
dragon fire we see men getting burned
alive these are the dragon seeds on
Dragon Stone who were trying to claim
the wild dragons to help rira in the
fight as we all know a dragon will not
let just anyone Mount them luckily for
Adam of Hall he was successful once
again we see Damon in full battle armor
on the back of his Dragon coraxis at the
end of this new teaser we have our money
shot of Amon riding vagar now the way it
looks it seems as if amond and vagar are
attacking rira and Cyrax but that's not
what's actually happening we will see
Amon Dan vagar during the battle at
rook's rest in that battle he will be
fighting alongside his brother Aon and
his Dragon Sunfire against rainy and
melees it will be an incredible fight
with three dragons and their Riders in
the Sky unfortunately rainy and melees
will not survive but she doesn't go down
without a fight they will severely
injure aegon and his Dragon before she
dies it will be nearly a full year
before he's ready to sit the Iron Throne
again meanwhile it's going to be
interesting to see what Amon does while
he rules in his absence I don't know
about all of you but the new teaser has
me so excited for the upcoming season
I'm not sure how anyone thinks the first
season will be better than this one let
me know if you think there was anything
I missed in the video also let me know
what scene has you most excited I did my
best at describing what I think I saw
although I did give a lot of information
I still wanted to leave out some things
because I don't want to reveal
everything from the season I've already
read Fire and Blood so I know most of
what will happen happen but I know the
writers are making up a lot of things as
well I'll be excited to see what they've
done differently George R Martin seem to
be very happy with their new direction
as always I want to thank everyone for
watching the video there will be a lot
more heading your way I'll be making new
videos every week until the new season
gets released I hope to see you all back
here for those also have a great day
everyone I'll see you soon
bye
[Music]
Lo